NOW INTO CNN FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE, NEW SANCTIONS ANNOUNCING
IN RESPONSE TO THIS MOVE BY
RUSSIA.
CNN WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JEREMY DIAMOND JOINING US NOW.
WALK US THROUGH THE STEPS AND
WHAT THIS MEANS EXACTLY.
>> Reporter: THE WHITE HOUSE
PLEDGED A SWIFT AND SEVERE
RESPONSE TO THE ANNEXATION BY
THE RUSSIAN PRUZ AND THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW.
THE UNITED STATES REJECTING THIS
ANNEXATION MOVE BY THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT AND ISSUING A SERIES
OF SEVERE SANCTIONS AGAINST
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS, THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND ALSO TARGETING
CRUCIALLY RUSSIA'S DEFENSE
SECTOR.
AND PROVIDERS OF WEAPONRY AND
OTHER SUPPLIES TO THIS DEFENSE
SECTOR THAT ARE BASED IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
A LIST OF THEM GOES FROM
BEGINNING WITH THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT SANCTIONING THE HEAD
OF RUSSIA CENTRAL BANK, THE
TREASURY AND STATE DEPARTMENT
ARE ALSO SANCTIONING RELATIVES
OF MEMBERS OF RUSSIA'S NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL, INCLUDING THE
WIFE OF RUSSIA'S PRIME MINISTER
AND HIS TWO ADULT CHILDREN.
THERE ARE VISA RESTRICTIONS ON
MONGUSH, ACCUSED TORTURING
UKRAINIAN PRISONERS OF WAR.
14 INTERNATIONAL SUPPLIERS
MILITARY HARDWARE ARE BEING
SANCTIONED HERE AND ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE ADDING 57
NEW ENTITIES TO ITS LIST FOR
EXPORT CONTROLS.
WE'VE ALSO JUST GOTTEN A
STATEMENT FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN
WHO CONDEMNS RUSSIA'S FRAUDULENT
ATTEMPT TO ANNEX SOVEREIGN
TERRITORY AND THIS IS A
VIOLATION OF INTERNATIONAL LAW,
TRAMPLING ON THE UNITED NATIONS
CHARTER AND SHOWS CONTEMPT FOR
PEACEFUL NATIONS EVERYWHERE.
AND THIS IS A CRUCIAL LINE FROM
HIS STATEMENT WHERE HE SAID,
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THESE ACTIONS
HAVE NO LEGITIMACY AND SAID THAT
THE U.S. WILL HONOR UKRAINE'S
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
BORDERS AND PLEDGES TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT AND ARMING UKRAINIAN
MILITARY.
ALL OF THIS IS NOTABLE BECAUSE
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS DRAWING A
HARDER LINE AND RAISING THE
SPECTER OF COURSE OF THE
POTENTIAL USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
WE HEARD HIM TODAY SAYING RUSSIA
WILL DEPEND AT ALL COSTS TIS
TERRITORY WHICH HE BELIEVES NOW
INCLUDED THESE FOUR UKRAINE
REGIONS WHICH HE IS ANNEXING AND
HE SAID THAT IT IS NOT A BLUFF,
THAT HE WILL DEFEND RUSSIAN
TERRITORY AT ALL COST USING ALL
MEANS.
THIS IS HEIGHTENING THE TENSIONS
IN THE REGION AND WE ARE SEEING
OF COURSE A STRONG U.S. RESPONSE
TO THESE MOVES.
>>> LET'S GO TO WASHINGTON RIGHT
NOW, AND SECRETARY ANTONY
BLINKEN IS TALKING ABOUT PARTS
OF ANNEXATION OF UKRAINE.
>> THERE ARE PARTS OF
INCORPORATION INTO RUSSIA.
AS I SAID LAST WEEK AT THE
UNITED STATES SECURITY COUNCIL,
THIS TERRITORY IS AND WILL
REREM
REMAIN UKRAINIAN AND THEY HAVE
EVERY RIGHT TO TAKE BACK THIS
TERRITORY THAT RUSSIA HAS SEIZED
FROM IT.
CANADA AND THE UNITED STATES AND
LIKE SO MANY NATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD SEE EYE TO EYE ON THIS,
AND THESE ARE THE LATEST IN THE
LONG LINE OF ACTIONS BY RUSSIA
SINCE IT LAUNCHED THE WAR OF
AGGRESSION AGAINST UKRAINE THAT
VIOLATE THE NATIONAL LAW AND
VIOLATE THE PRINCIPLES OF
SOVEREIGNTY WHICH UNDERPIN THE
INTERNATIONAL ORDER SO NECESSARY
OF KEEPING PEACE AND SECURITY
AROUND THE WORLD, AND ALL OF
THIS SHOWS THE KREMLIN'S UTTER
CONTEMPT FOR THE RIGHTS AND WILL
OF THE WILL OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
I ALSO MADE CLEAR THAT WHEN
RUSSIA MADE THIS MOVE, THE
UNITED STATES AND OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS WOULD IMPOSE SEVERE AND
SWIFT CAUSE FOR THOSE WHO TRIED
TO CHANGE THE STATUS OF THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, AND WE HAVE
DONE THAT AND THE EUROPEAN UNION
AND CANADA AND U.K. ARE DOING
THE SAME.
AND WE WILL HOLD TO ACCOUNT ANY
INDIVIDUAL, ENTITY OR COUNTRY
THAT PROVIDES POLITICAL OR
ECONOMIC SUPPORT FOR PRESIDENT
PUTIN'S ILLEGAL ATTEMPTS TO
CHANGE THE STAT STUS OF THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SECRETARY AND
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE WILL
IMPOSE HIGH SANCTIONS IS FOR
THOSE ENTITIES AND INDIVIDUALS
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF RUSSIA
THAT SUPPORT IN ANY WAY THE SHAM
REFERENDA AND PURPORTED
ANNEXATION AND PARTS OF
ANNEXATION.
WE WILL TAKE ACTION OF THOSE
SHAM ANNEXATION, AND IF RUSSIA
BLOCKS THE SECURITY COUNCIL FROM
BLOCKING SUPPORTED SANCTION, WE
WILL ASK THE U.N. WHERE EVERY
NATION WILL HAVE A VOTE TO
ENFORCE THAT VOTE.
EVERY COUNTRY HAS A STAKE IN
THOSE STEPS.
AS THE SECRETARY GUTERRES SAID
THIS WEEK, THE CHART SER CLEAR,
ANY ANNEXATION OF THE STATE'S
TERRITORY BY ANOTHER STATE BY
THE THREAT OR USE OF FORCE IS A
VIOLATION OF ITS CHARTER OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
THE U.S., CANADA AND OTHER
ALLIED FORCES WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT THE AGGRESSION OF RUSSIA.
WITH NEW SECURITY ASSISTANCE
THAT WE HAVE ANNOUNCED THIS
WEEK, THE UNITED STATES HAS
GIVEN $16.9 BILLION ASSISTANCE
TO UKRAINE GOING BACK TO JANUARY
2021.
IN THE MEETING THE FOREIGN
MINISTER AND THE UNITED STATES
HAVE CONTINUED TO SUPPORT WAYS
TO SUPPORT UKRAINE IN THE
DIFFICULT WINTER AHEAD, THE
INDEPENDENT SOVEREIGN FOR
UKRAINE IS STEADFAST.
THE UNITED STATES AND CANADA
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
AT THE G7 TO HELP THE
POPULATIONS HARDEST HIT BY
PRESIDENT PUTIN'S WAR OF CHOICE,
INCLUDING GETTING LIFE SAVING
AID TO PEOPLE AFFECTED BY THE
UNPRECEDENTED GLOBAL FOOD CRISIS
AND MAKE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
WE AND THE NATO ALLIES ARE
PREPARED TO PROTECT EVERY INCH
OF NATO TERRITORY